My name is Angus McFadyen
I'm a silversmith an engraver.
I've been doing it since 1984.
Engraving is one of these things that when it becomes know that you engrave,
then you get asked to do jobs like this, make a sundial replica.
Engraving is basically drawing on metal.
So the first thing you have to do is to draw on the metal and the simplest thing to use is a pencil.
Then once you've drawn on the metal, you need to mark it in more permanently before you start engraving.
So we use a scribe to do that
that you can then follow with the graver.
And the graver is cutting metal so you're removing metal
which leaves you with a line of sorts of depths or widths according to the job.
Very versatile process.
Brass is a material that is used a lot particularly for this type of thing, instruments in the past.
This brass for this sundial actually, although it is machining brass which has quite a high lead content
in the alloy, it's actually quite hard to cut.
Engraving is it extremely time-consuming.
There are no shortcuts, there's nowhere to
hide, there's no cheating.
You've got to do it as nicely as you possibly can.
It can be tiring when you're on a big job and it's just day in day out, cutting away,
but at the same time, I love it.
And I think if you didn't enjoy doing it it
would just be a chore
and you wouldn't do totally good work I don't think either.
Even now when you do a cut that you're really pleased with, it's quite exciting still.
It was really fascinating to look closely at the original sundial.
There are marks at the beginnings or ends of some of the cuts
which most people probably wouldn't even notice
and they're not mistakes, they're not errors but they're marks which probably only an engraver will notice.
There's this instant connect with the person who did it and that's lovely.
You know, to go back that many years and just have instant connection with the person who did it.
And you say 'oh yeah, I know what was going on there, I know what you did there.'
That personal touch is something you only get when someone's sat down and done it themselves.